my name is Frank grapes and my London
taxi driver and I hate London traffic
London's traffic is awful it's always
been bad it's getting worse it's getting
worse by the day this is great example
in all the way across the bridge the
entire length of the bridge
bumper-to-bumper traffic South now the
frustration with it is not is not the
traffic and tough side it's definitely
the infrastructure it's the reason that
there's traffic there's no plan I
certainly if there is the people were
planning it well those tiny guns get no
jobs
well actually they do have a plan
take Londoners off the roads and put
them underground to accomplish that
London is undertaking the largest
construction project in Europe an
insanely huge expansion of its metro
system called cross rail cross rail is
the new east-west railway for London
it's a high-speed high-frequency Metro
service and who are you I'm Simon Wright
I'm the program director for cross rail
when completed cross rail will add more
than 60 miles of train and 10 new
stations to London's underground
bringing mass transit to 1.5 million
people who didn't really have it before
and if 1.5 million people can take the
train
that's 1.5 million people who don't have
to get around London using other methods
like cars I'm a firm believer in
continuing to incentivize people not to
drive in London and railways are an
environmentally positive way to get
large numbers of people around safely
and efficiently and to to keep big
cities moving can you tell me where we
are right now you know where we are in
London
we'd be in Holborn area in central
London or running through the eastbound
of what will be the new cross rail
railway line
making room underground for a
million-and-a-half new commuters is no
small feat 10,000 people have been
working 24 hours a day for eight years
to get to this point and they still have
three years to go 7 million tons of
Earth had to be moved out of the way IVs
hello boring machines or TBMs each TBM
is a 500 foot long mobile factory that
grinds up and removes dirt and rock and
installs the walls of the tunnels as it
goes walls that are intended to last for
more than a hundred years it seems sort
of amazing that something like this
could even be accomplished I mean
particularly coming from a place like
New York where we can barely figure out
on an annus of the subway line in 80
years of course as you might imagine
none of this comes cheap the cost is
fourteen point eight billion that's our
funding envelope
overall the scale of it is is absolutely
enormous and of course very challenging
indeed that's the thing about mass
transit it's massive it takes massive
amounts of money massive numbers of
people and massive amounts of time
and after all that the most important
question still remains will Crossrail
fix London's traffic problem answer no
not entirely but it will go a long way
towards alleviating current congestion
so this is not the end of the game this
is simply a step along the way